siento que los estudiantes
estereotípicos de la ivy league son
realistas y engreídos siento que esta
puerta me encaja con ese estereotipo
siento que estas personas no importan
esas personas no importan jubilee
reunimos a siete estudiantes de la ivy
league estudio la edil y estudio del
estudio la bilis estudio la ivy league
estudio en live leak estudio en la bilis
1 abandonó la universidad si el grupo
descubre quién es el mentiroso se
repartirán un premio en efectivo que si
el mentiroso sobrevive ganará el premio
muy bien es el impostor el impostor
estudiantes de la ivy league de que años
son si no me gradué en mayo de 2021
estoy en el primer año de la carta el
ser año 2022 primer año de princeton
estoy en el segundo a también estoy en
su último año cuál es su restaurante
favorito en la brown
yo diría que es works muy bien muy bien
y el tuyo white les hizo una pregunta
superficial sobre los restaurantes que
les gustaban a los estudiantes de la
brown que es hacia el área de
providencia y solo sabe lo que se come
en esa zona en qué club están inscritos
extracurriculares el club de finanzas el
fútbol en la brown y me llegó una carta
después de cuatro años del barça de
florida no sé si es igual en sus
universidades reciben alguna carta anal
es xavi yo no hago de muertes
lamentablemente y su cuento de ser
atleta y de graduarse me parece
demasiado perfecto aguanta en harvard yo
estudio radio estoy en wild cats a
capela
estoy en el grupo de rock de la prenda
también el grupo de bailes streak live
on estamos colaborando con el botija de
la princeton por dios tengo amigos en el
body jael ya pudo buscar prinstein
puntocom ver cuál era el equipo de danza
de la princeton y memorizarlo estoy en
una hermandad llamada athena y también
están en la revista de filosofía llamada
get fly estoy en el club de finanzas de
la brown y en el sigma cae
o dios
voto de participantes quienes el
impostor
caribe su atuendo parece ser de nueva
york y columbia verdad como sacada de un
episodio de golf de austin
mi instinto me dice que es ella algo me
dijo que votará por ella
carl y llámame después
[Música]
eres muy conversadora es un poco más
abierta y seguro vieron que comparada a
ella fui un poco más callada y también
algo tímida hay cosas han pasado
recientemente en su universidad tenemos
una fiesta hoy y jugaremos contra pen
fueron el partido entre harvard y brown
no yo jugué los otros años
fuiste al partido entre
sí cuando helen mencionó el juego de
fútbol que este conocimiento común fue
algo muy fácil saberlo si estuviera
fingiendo ser un estudiante de la ivy
league diría que estoy en primer año
para encubrir las cosas que no sé de la
universidad cuál sería como una insignia
en columbia que algo que a todos les
gusta es ir a dj es muy grande email
están obsesionados con esos lugares pero
a mí no me gusta estamos en la ivy
league
yo sé poco de columbia no puedo saber si
lo que dice es verdad cuando hablo de
los restaurantes nadie dijo si lo
conozco lo conozco en la harvard y está
la estatua de lyon harvard es la estatua
de las tres mentiras porque no estoy en
harvard no fundó la harvard y el estatua
está mal la fecha en que se fundó
literalmente todos los de primer año
originales
me despierto todas las mañanas igual
estudiantes del domino local ellos no
saben que están tocando yo pensé eso es
algo que cualquiera podría saber al
pasar por allí en la priísta en acabamos
de tener una fiesta y sanford vino y
actúa en el club de comida estoy usando
una pequeña pulsera de la fiesta en el
green fue una fiesta muy divertida
nosotros tuvimos nuestra fiesta de fin
de clases y básicamente todos vienen con
sombreros y bastones caminan por las
olas luego tienes que montar un show del
sombrero de tu amigo y
me gusta mike's calzones todos suelen ir
ahí a comer calzones después de haber
bebido demasiado es el lugar ideal está
en la calle tir que es una calle
principal del campus que tiene todos
esos restaurantes
siguió hablando de los calzones y
lugares de comida al azar y pensé le
debe gustar mucho ese lugar
no sabe mucho sobre el abrazo sienten
que encajan en el estereotipo de
estudiante de su universidad es una
buena pregunta sinceros siento que los
estudiantes estereotípicos de la ivy
league son estilistas incredible harán
siento que mucha gente me encaja muy
bien yo siento que esas personas
de verdad esas personas no importa
se supone que la brown es una ciudad
pero también es muy elitista soy sincero
yo siento que encajo en columbia está
cierto un mundo el individuo que hace
uso de la ciudad pero al mismo tiempo
está llena de un montón de
internacionales elitistas y yo no uso
esa chaqueta de canadá gustos
colores
alto de bote por kylie porque me parece
un poco superficial
creo que austin estaba un poco fuera de
lugar porque no respondió algunas
preguntas en la última ronda así que me
pareció sospechoso
[Música]
ah
fue traición me traicionaron creo que es
porque dije max dos veces y luego la
calle tíber así que parecía que sólo
tenía una cosa de qué hablar nueva regla
a partir de ahora cada vez que voten por
alguien que no sea el impostor se
reducirá el monto del premio
por favor levanten la mano si quieren
seguir jugando
a levantaron todos tercera ronda unamos
nuestros cerebros de la ivy league
así que se pierde la mitad del dinero si
votamos a la persona equivocada
siento que ya creada votamos a la
persona pero si también quedamos muchos
aquí si ex para votar y poder terminar
el juego en ese momento sólo el plan a
seguir como permanecer en el juego y
repartir el premio cuál es la política
del gobi de en este momento tienen cosas
que te llevas dos meses por semana ahora
tenemos que hacer la prueba moneda
hisopo y todos los otros nos hacen la
prueba dos veces al mes
tienes un poco impactante pero pensé que
en columbia estaban locos pero no
estamos obligados a hacer la prueba
ellos solo en la ciudad no tampoco
es sobre esta ronda podemos renunciar a
esta ronda si estamos pensando ya quiero
terminar esto yo no sospecho de nadie
visitante mouse
sentí que podría ir a otra universidad
de nueva york hay muchas aquí al bar y
lo siento tengo que escribir un nombre
no es algo personal samara escribió
mucho creí que había escrito blazing
porque su nombre es el más largo que el
resto de los otros así que
[Música]
adiós
adiós adiós
yo estoy profundamente
molesta por favor levanten la mano si
quieren seguir jugando
y muy bien entonces ahora termine el
juego que dios nos ayude
yo tengo la pulsera de la fiesta
si se encienden las luces verdes
significa que sacaron al impostor y
ganan si se encienden las luces rojas
significa que el impostor todavía está
en la caja y pierden
vamos a ver
ah
si
bien el dichoso
el estudiante impostor de la ivy league
puede dar un paso al frente en
yo conozco body works
también increíble mi compañera es de
brand
cuál es tu historia a los 19 años dejé
informática en la universidad producto
reserve un boleto de ida san francisco y
comencé una nueva empresa ahora dirijo
una escuela de mercadeo donde ayudó a
otras personas a conseguir un trabajo en
el mundo del mercadeo es gratuito porque
creemos que independientemente de a
donde vaya o cuál sea su experiencia eso
no debería definir sus oportunidades
nunca sospeché que fuera ella yo pensaba
que era 'hosting' no me fue bien en la
secundaria así que no me habrían
aceptado en la ivy league pero eso no
significa que no me puede ir bien en el
resto de mi vida lo que ocurrió en
realidad no significa nada ya que
teniendo en cuenta que es la primera
generación que tiene educación
universitaria y que mis padres son
inmigrantes ir a la abi significa mucho
para mí nunca pensé que entraría en
harvard entré cuando tenía 16 y me
sentía abruma si yo pude entrar siento
que cualquiera podría perseguir sus
sueños porque nunca se sabe lo que
podría suceder ese es el final del juego
y queremos agradecerles a todos ustedes
y darles un regalo
que
[Música]
no podemos tomarnos una foto chicos
ustedes se equivocaron con una persona y
mi culo
ellos recogen el ligero